Valentina ooh wild card I don't know I
mean she's an odd character huh
she isn't odd character she was like
three different people her first season
yes you know what I'm an ambassador of
drag race and I celebrate people for
what they're good at
nobody has ever even competed with the
beauty of her face that was Trixie
Mattel of RuPaul's Drag Race Fame
speaking to et on lines bystander about
her fabulous drag persona excuse me her
friend Valentina
the star is joining the new cast of
RuPaul's Drag Race all-stars for season
four RuPaul officially announced the
cast today and we are crying glitter
tears listen honey you're gonna have to
catch me up on all of the news today
with the man after ten seasons of drag
race All Stars gets better and better
because you got again ten seasons worth
of Queens to pick from right and there's
a reason why this show won an Emmy this
past year you guys for Best
reality-competition program because it
is lit if you don't watch it you gotta
aah
but let's break down some of the biggest
standouts I think this season all-stars
for starting with Valentina Trixie was
saying that when Valentina was first on
the show back in season nine we got we
kind of got like a poor version of her
it was or whoever it was an early time
for Valentina but she has glowed up
y'all the question though on everybody's
mind is because she was famously
famously known for refusing to take off
her mask during a lip sync for her life
Andrew made her I think this time she'll
keep the mask off I think she's gonna do
okay yeah next oh my god a couple of my
favorites Monique Hart and Monet
exchange Monique and Monet are both from
season 10 Monique you all know if you
followed her
she's the brown cow stunner and Monet
sponge queen both from the last season
coming back for the crown Monet actually
was Miss Congeniality this last season
she's also just a killer lip syncher so
I'm predicting she's gonna go far in
this competition a couple of other my
other of my favorites I got a shout out
Manila Luzon another Filipino Queen so
hard to pick a favorite
okay talk about how we're covering so
many Filipinos this week yeah
and Vincent and now Manila she's a
legendary season 3 runner-up with a
equally as legendary lip sync to Donna
summers MacArthur Park she was also the
very first season of all-stars the
question is its third time the charm and
finally we cannot talk about this new
cast without talking about a legend
herself Latrice Royale she was voted
season fours in this Congeniality she is
large and charged bold and beautiful and
my favorite to win you know who I'm
excited for oh he lives very oh and
Jason Carter he's a part of the pit crew
and the pit crew yes she's an all-stars
4 so that means we're gonna get a lot of
man candy
yes premiere edition Friday oh we sure
will premieres Friday December 14th at
8:00 7:00 central on vh1 watching
[Music]